[Music]
hey wisecrack Jared here if your bunker
has reliable Wi-Fi you may have noticed
certain word making the rounds lately
and a growing coronavirus crisis the
carnivores crisis to the Cova 19 crisis
coronavirus crisis the coronavirus
crisis the corona crisis kovat 19 is a
crisis but what exactly is a crisis the
meaning of the word seems obvious enough
but as we're about to find out there's
actually a lot more to it than you might
think
philosophers from Lao Zhu to Voltaire
have been grappling with the idea of
crisis for millennia and now we're going
to throw our masks in the ring I mean
not literally
I've lost my spare welcome to as
wisecrack edition on the philosophy of
crisis in everyday speech crisis is
sometimes lumped in with words like
disaster catastrophe etc that is words
that call to mind some big terrible
event that causes a lot of damage but
the technical definition of the term is
much more specific the English word
crisis has its root in the Greek word
cronin which means to separate or choose
ancient Greek physicians use the term to
refer to a precise moment in the
development of an illness when a doctor
must apply a particular treatment
according to the Hippocratic medical
tradition failing to act decisively
during this brief window of opportunity
could lead to the death of the patient
for Aristotle the root crane Ian
referred to a decision made in the
political sphere that is a choice
between contradictory options with the
potential to create lasting changes in
society a crisis is a decisive moment in
which there is the possibility for great
harm and great change and after which
things can no longer be the same one
historical crisis in particular
demonstrates how a devastating events
can become the catalyst for government
overhaul redistribution of power among
institutions and even changes in
religious thought I'm talking of course
about the Lisbon earthquake of 1755
okay so unless you're a history buff you
may not have heard of that one
but this natural disaster and the way
that individuals and institutions
responded to it contributed to major
changes in the way that Europeans
related to their governments and had a
big influence on some of the key
thinkers behind the Scientific
Revolution on November 1st of that year
while many were in church celebrating
All Saints Day a massive earthquake
struck the capital of Portugal the
seismic activity leveled many of the
city's buildings crushing the people
inside and as icing on the cake
triggered a big ol tsunami that added to
the destruction in the chaos that
followed a massive fire broke out and
burned away much of what remained it
killed 60 thousand people according to
some estimates the disaster sparked a
crisis of authority specifically the
authority of the church versus the
authority of the state while the Marquis
of Pombal de facto ruler of Portugal
wanted Lisbon i'ts to focus on
distributing food efficiently in
rebuilding the city prominent Jesuit
priest Gabriel Mallick Rita urged people
to spend their time repenting for the
sins that he felt had brought God's
judgment upon the city thankfully that
kind of thing doesn't happen anymore
u.s. senator called me and asked me if
Hurricane Katrina was judgement from God
I said yes the crisis forced a choice
between the authority of the church and
that of the state specifically a new
absolutist form of authority which would
place ultimate decision-making power in
the hands of a sovereign at the center
of a more secular government by ignoring
the church's plan for disaster response
pombles actions would represent a huge
departure from centuries of church
involvement in state affairs as seen in
the coronation of Charlemagne by Pope
Leo the 3rd all the way back in 800 C II
in the end pombal made the choice for
Lisbon by having mal agree to publicly
humiliated strangled to death and his
body burnt at the stake
like all crises Lisbon was at a critical
juncture in the Greek sense was the city
to respond to the disaster with thoughts
and prayers or you know by digging
survivors out from the rubble but it
also became a critical juncture in
philosophy in the wider European world
the catastrophe also led to a crisis of
faith and philosophy that helped spawned
completely new ways of thinking about
the world and its relation to the divine
before tectonic plates decided to treat
Lisbon like an etch-a-sketch early
enlightenment intellectuals spent a lot
of time exploring theodicy The Odyssey
is a branch of philosophy focused on
reconciling the problem of evil with the
existence of a loving omnipotent God
philosophers like Gottfried Leibniz
argued that we live in the best of all
possible worlds
a universe in which evils like natural
disaster and war ultimately serve an
inherent good divine purpose which is
beyond our mortal understanding for at
least a few decades this very nice idea
was reasonably persuasive to his fellow
thinkers until Lisbon in coming to grips
with the disaster French philosopher
Voltaire Zoomer to live mrs. Boomer came
to believe that the idea of an
inherently good world was Horsch against
contemporary days philosophers like
jean-jacques Rousseau who defended the
notion of an essentially good universe
ruled by some benevolent force Voltaire
argued that our cosmos is fundamentally
amoral neither good nor bad in the wake
of the Lisbon earthquake Voltaire wrote
and published candy an entire effing
novella whose primary purpose is to
roast Leibniz and his metaphysical
optimism the story follows Candide a
young man who learns like Nietzsche and
philosophy from one professor Pangloss
full Terra portrays Pangloss as a
buffoon whose dedication to optimism
leads him to absurd divine
justifications for minor trivia and
major evils alike Voltaire has this live
net stand in say for instance that we
all have noses because God was
thoughtful enough to give us a place for
our spectacles and that it's ultimately
all right that Columbus brought syphilis
back from the new world because hey at
least Europe got chocolate out of it and
you thought your tweets were petty the
crisis of Lisbon pushed European thought
to its limits exposing the cracks in not
only church authority but also the realm
of philosophy in the decades following
the crisis the philosophical community
opted for a more secular paradigm
leaving questions about God the theology
and contributing to the removal of
theological questions from philosophy at
the same time responsibility for
understanding disasters shifted over to
the emerging field of science
intellectuals let-off trying to figure
out why bad things occur and started
investigating how they happen of course
other crises perform similar roles in
the aftermath of the Holocaust
philosophers were wracked with basic
questions of how did so-called
civilization birth this monstrosity even
the rise of fascism has been attributed
to a series of crises which at critical
junctures went the wrong way the
arguments of thinkers like Italian
philosopher Antonio Gramsci suggests
that the conflicts exposed by long term
social change enabled totalitarian
movements to seek out even more
repressive means of control and for Karl
Marx the whole theory that the world
will move to communism is predicated on
the idea that capitalism generates
economic crises and people will respond
to those crises by mass revolt now
whether it's an earthquake and economic
collapse or a destructive political
movement the point is a crisis tugs at
the very structure of our world it
exposes the cracks and weaknesses
economic crises can point to
shortcomings in economic infrastructure
natural disasters bring to light rampant
inequality ranging from unsafe housing
to food insecurity like the torch happy
palm ball we are also facing a crisis
which will force some pretty big
decisions over the next few years
Cobin 19 and our response to it will be
sure to highlight a score of problems
embedded in society take for instance
how different countries responded to the
pandemic which revealed very strength or
weakness of that different system of
government while some have noted that
China's authoritarian government was
able to successfully stem the spread of
the virus the flipside is that the same
government's lack of transparency
allowed the infection to spread in
secrecy in its early stages on the other
hand democracies have greater
transparency as well as a free press
that's able to share information and
criticize or support official policy but
those same democracies may be hesitant
to enforce lockdown with heavy-handed
policing and stricter rules but pushing
the limits of the democratic process
isn't the only problem this crisis is
exposing it's also exposing issues in an
area that may seem totally unrelated
industrial meat production
on the human front the fast-paced
production lines of the meat industry
has workers laboring closer to each
other than ever and so it's no surprise
that Tyson reported nearly 900 cases of
kovat at one plant alone but to zoom out
a little Co bit exposes just how
vulnerable we are to diseases that find
a welcomed breeding ground in factory
farms evolutionary biologist Rob Wallace
has pointed out that modern animal feed
Lots which pack thousands of animals
together in close quarters are the
little bears bed to the flu viruses
Goldilocks
a cozy biological stew in which to
fester and mutate both the 2009 h1n1
virus and the 1918 Spanish flu yeah
that flu have been traced back to
American feed lots now we're not trying
to take away anyone's hamburgers and if
anyone tries to take ours we've
collectively sworn to cut a bit still
with the u.s. meat supply dwindling as
factory farms and processing plants fall
to cope and outbreaks it might be worth
exploring whether we absolutely have to
get our steak and pork chops by cramming
thousands of animals together in
monotonous unsanitary conditions for the
duration of their short lives or whether
there might be a better way another
weakness that kovat and similar diseases
exposed is how structural inequalities
of all kinds can help create pockets of
highly vulnerable people within the
broader population of a city nation etc
with diminished access to testing and
treatment these groups endure
disproportionate pain and death and can
become the unwilling vectors for the
spread of disease to other parts of the
population the virus has thrown these
effects into sharp relief and in the
process brought up questions about how
we ought to structure our economies
governments and societies and who ought
to control them and how everybody has
something to say about everyone else's
response to the pandemic whether they're
shaking a fist at Florida beachgoers or
seriously considering the upside of
centralized despotism people everywhere
are thinking hard about where power
belongs even in the u.s. federal
interventions that would have sounded
crazy just a few months ago are already
up and running to trillion-dollar
stimulus package anyone check plays
while no one knows for sure what our
world will look like on the other side
of this particular crisis one thing is
certain things will never be quite the
same but what do you think wisecrack
what are some of the biggest
decisions we face as a result of the
Cova 19 crisis what might change over
the next few years let us know what you
think in the comments below
big thanks to all our patrons and be
sure to subscribe and ring that bell and
as always thanks for watching guys peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]